now less than 4 500 miles away from the
Moon continuing to grow closer ahead of
the outbound powered flyby burn again
we're looking for that burn in an hour
and 25 minutes from now 7 44 a.m eastern
time Orion is traveling at 757 miles per
hour this is a live view from the
spacecraft itself it is from a camera
mounted on one of the solar array wings
we will lose communication with the
spacecraft as it passes behind the Moon
that loss of communication will occur
for approximately 34 minutes and again
we're tracking that here
that loss of communication will start at
7 26 a.m so one hour and seven minutes
from now
we'll remain on air throughout the time
that Orion is Out Of Reach from our
satellites here on Earth
Orion is now
4182 miles away from the Moon 233 089
miles away from our home of planet Earth
this is a live view from the track
Artemis or the nasa.gov track Artemis
feature it's a Telemetry driven
animation called Arrow the Artemis
real-time orbit website that you can
access anytime during the mission that
allows you to keep a look at where Orion
is and what phase of the mission it's in
as well as take a look at what's coming
up next for the spacecraft
what's coming up next this morning is
the outbound powered flyby burn at 7 44
A.M
eastern time when Orion will be 328
statute miles above the Moon this
prepares us for the closest Approach at
6 at 7 57 a.m eastern time when Orion
will be just 81 statute miles above our
lunar neighbor
currently spacecraft's traveling 824
miles per hour and during the time of
OPF the spacecraft will be traveling at
5023 miles per hour
we are now less than 4 000 miles away
from the Moon actually 309 3900 to be
exact traveling at 876 miles per hour we
are one hour and 12 minutes away from
the outbound powered flyby burn
scheduled for 7 44 a.m eastern time
everything on track for the burn this
morning that closest approach after the
burn we will be just 80 miles above the
lunar surface again this is an uncrewed
flight test we have no astronauts aboard
the Artemis One mission we're doing
we're doing this mission in preparation
for astronauts to fly aboard for Artemis
2 and our future missions in the Artemis
program
again this is a Telemetry driven
animation you can track Artemis anytime
at nasa.gov track Artemis through the
Artemis real-time orbit website also
known as Arrow that'll give you the
stats on the spacecraft as well as where
we are during the mission
this is live anytime of the day or night
so when we're not on air you can still
keep up with where Orion is
at the start of our broadcast just an
hour and 20 minutes ago Orion was over 7
000 miles away from the Moon we're now
coming up on
3630 miles away from the Moon 233 000
miles away from Earth and traveling at
940 miles per hour that velocity has
increased as well and will continue to
do so at the time of the OPF or outbound
powered flyby burn at 7 44 a.m Eastern
Orion will be traveling at over five
thousand twenty three miles per hour
we're tracking outbound powered flyby
burn to take place one hour and six
minutes from now the go for that burn
came two days ago from the mission
manage management team when they met for
their daily briefing
now one hour from the outbound power to
flyby maneuver targeted for 7 44 a.m
Eastern Time
foreign
is 3 300 miles away from the moon
traveling 1025 miles per hour
thanks for joining us for our live
coverage this morning this is a live
view from a camera on the tip of Orion's
solar array Wing aimed at our
destination the moon we are now 3098
miles away from the moon traveling at
1085 miles per hour just 56 minutes away
from the outbound powered flyby that
outbound powered flyby is targeted for 7
44 a.m Eastern Time
we're happy to have brought you this
extended coverage this morning and for
now I'm going to pass it off to my
colleague Sandra Jones to take you all
the way through outbound powered flyby
we're continuing to bring you live
coverage of the upcoming outbound
outbound powered flyby of Orion now
scheduled for 53 minutes and 30 seconds
from now
Orion is already in the moon's sphere of
influence
and yesterday the team completed a
successful outbound trajectory
correction burn
this burn helps set us up for the OPF
burn again coming up in about 53 minutes
from now
at the time of the OPF burn Orion will
be 328 statute miles above the Moon
and then just a short time from then
Orion will complete its closest approach
to the moon at 81 miles above the lunar
surface
now during this time we will not have
signal with Orion because it will be
traveling behind the back side of the
moon however we expect to regain
Communications once Orion swings back
around to the other side and is back on
the deep space Network
the outbound powered flyby will send
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft once
around the Moon toward entry into what
we call a distant retrograde orbit
following this Orion will remain in the
distant retrograde orbit for one long
elliptical orbit around the Moon lasting
about six days now this orbit is called
distant due to the High Altitude from
the moon it's about 40 000 miles past
the moon in its orbit which is actually
30 000 miles farther than the previous
record set during Apollo 13.
and this will be the farthest in space
any spacecraft built for humans will
have ever flown
this orbit is also called retrograde
because Orion will be traveling around
the Moon opposite the direction the moon
travels around the Earth
this Dro provides a highly stable orbit
where little fuel is required to stay
for an extended trip in deep space in
order to put Orion's systems through its
Paces into the tests in an environment
far from Earth ahead of crude flights
here in Mission Control Houston things
remain relatively calm now five hours
five days five hours since Orion's
liftoff aboard the space launch system
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
the next major Milestone that we're
tracking ahead of today's burn will be a
go no-go poll where flight director Rick
labrode will pull the team here in
mission control on key systems required
for the upcoming burn
on your screen you're continuing to get
a live view of the Moon taken from one
of the solar array Wing or saw cameras
on board the Orion spacecraft
Orion is traveling at
1248 miles per hour and is only 2 600
miles away from the moon at this time
again upon closest approach Orion will
be about 80 miles off of the surface of
the Moon
now we will be in that anticipated and
expected loss of signal during that
closest approach however we do expect to
regain signal with Orion just about two
minutes after the closest approach where
we will regain Communications with the
vehicle
if you're just joining us we're bringing
you live coverage of today's upcoming
outbound powered flyby burn which will
slingshot us around the back side of the
moon you are continuing to get views of
the moon in real time here on your
screen from a solar array Wing camera on
board Orion
today's burn will take place with the
orbital maneuvering system or ohms
engine this engine has been used several
times throughout Orion's five-day
Journey to the Moon
this is that large engine located on the
bottom of the service module
and the engine can provide six thousand
pounds of thrust
today's burn will last two minutes and
30 seconds but the burn can be used for
burns lasting up to 16 minutes in length
the ohms engine onboard Orion is a
repurposed space shuttle orbital
maneuvering system engine that has flown
in space before
it flew on 19 space shuttle flights
beginning with sts-41g in October of
1984 and ending with sts-112 in October
of 2002.
now the ohms engine is not the only
engine on board the Orion spacecraft
there are also eight auxiliary engines
these are located on the bottom of the
service module in as well but in four
sets of two
these are used to provide trajectory
Corrections and as a backup to the main
engine and each engine provides about 1
100 pounds of thrust
in total there are 33 engines aboard
Orion and here on your screen you are
getting a quick glimpse of
planet Earth
thank you
we do expect to regain those videos and
imagery here shortly but for now you're
looking at a Telemetry driven animation
of Orion and its location as you can see
here on your screen speed continuing to
pick up now at 1
369 miles per hour
over
232
000 miles from home but only 2 000 miles
away from the Moon
again at closest approach will be just
over 80 miles above the lunar surface
continuing to close in on the back side
of the moon
at this time we're 15 minutes away from
the planned go no-go poll where flight
director Rick labrode will pull the team
here in Mission Control ahead of today's
upcoming outbound power to fly by burn
and you're looking at a live view inside
Mission Control Houston we're in the
white flight control room today they are
in the center of your screen who just
sat down is flight director Rick labrode
who is leading the team here in Mission
Control this morning
sitting next to him is another flight
director Zeb Scoville
we'll have the opportunity to speak with
Zeb here in just a few minutes about the
upcoming burn
Orion is now 2 000 miles away from the
Moon continuing to close in on its
destination for this particular burn the
back side of the moon
the outbound powered flyby is the goal
of today's operation
this outbound powered flyby will send
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft once
around the Moon toward entry into
distant retrograde orbit
following this Orion will remain in the
distant retrograde orbit for one long
elliptical orbit around the Moon which
will last about six days
following this Orion will perform a
similar maneuver called the return
powered flyby which will put it on the
trajectory to return back to Earth ahead
of a Splashdown in the Pacific Ocean on
December 11th
now the first time a NASA vehicle flew
behind the backside of the Moon with
crew on board was first done during
Apollo 8. and here you are looking at a
live view of the Orion spacecraft from
the solar array wing with the Moon
in the distance of the screen
the Earth in the distant frame of the
screen and the Moon up close again we
are now less than 2 000 miles away from
the moon but over 200 000 miles away
from planet Earth
myself
Orion started its Journey five days ago
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
where it launched aboard the space
launch system
Orion has been traveling to the moon
ever since performing checkouts of its
systems as this is an uncrewed test
flight
it's critical that NASA tests out the
hardware and systems aboard Orion the
head of flying a crew onboard Artemis 2.
pick one two three four five
good morning and welcome to the Johnson
Space Center in Houston Texas I'm NASA's
Sandra Jones and we're we're bringing
you live coverage from Mission Control
Houston of the upcoming outbound powered
flyby in which Orion will fly behind the
moon and perform a burn utilizing the
orbital maneuvering system engine which
was checked out on Tuesday following
launch of Orion atop the space launch
system the engine has been performing
well and has completed a series of
additional expected trajectory
correction Burns and all spacecraft
systems are performing well now over
five days into the flight of Artemis 1.
today we're in the white flight control
room where flight director Rick labrode
is leading the team on console for
today's flyby and burn just moments ago
flight director Rick Road pulled the
team here in mission control and we are
go for the OPF burn we do expect to lose
signal of Orion as it travels behind the
back side of the moon as the moon will
be blocking the direct site to the deep
space Network we're tracking that loss
of signal to begin just about 10 min
minutes from now at 6 25 a.m Central and
will last just over 34 minutes while in
the loss of signal the outbound powered
flyby will take place with the orbital
maneuvering system engine at 6 44 a.m
Central
the outbound powered flyby will send
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft once
around the Moon toward entry into
distant retrograde orbit following this
Orion will remain in the distant
retrograde orbit for one long elliptical
orbit around the Moon lasting about six
days
at this time Orion is only 1 600 miles
away from the Moon
and you see this view on your screen as
Orion continues to approach the back
side of the moon now traveling at over 1
776 miles per hour
and on the lower middle of your screen
you do see that's us that's home
232 000 miles away from Earth
Orion launched from the Kennedy Space
Center in Florida five days ago
and we are now 25 minutes away from the
outbound powered flyby maneuver
today's burn will occur with the orbital
maneuvering system or ohms engine which
has been used several times already in
Orion's flight
the ohms engine is located on the bottom
of the service module and is the largest
engine aboard Orion
it can provide 6 000 pounds of thrust
and is equipped to help steer the
spacecraft and can be used in some abort
cases if necessary to safely return
Orion to Earth
now today's burn will last for two
minutes and 30 seconds but the Ohm's
engine can fire for up to 16 minutes
the ohms engine is a repurposed space
shuttle orbital maneuvering system
engine that has flown in space several
times before 19 times in fact beginning
on Space Shuttle flight
sts-41g in October of 1984 and ending
with sts-112 in October 2002.
now just about five minutes from now we
do expect to lose signal from Orion as
it travels behind the Moon that loss of
signal will last for 34 minutes however
once Orion emerges from the back side of
the moon and regains Communications on
the deep space Network we do expect to
regain Communications with the vehicle
the burn will occur at 6 44 a.m Central
while we are in that loss of signal
and we'll also have the closest Approach
at that time period when we are in the
loss of signal as well that closest
Approach at 6 57 a.m Central when Orion
will be just 81 miles above the lunar
surface
again if you're just joining us you are
looking at a view from the solar array
Wing or saw camera on board the Orion
spacecraft which is five days into its
Mission just 1 400 miles away from the
Moon
we'll continue to see the moon grow
larger in the frame here in the next
couple of minutes before we do lose
signal from Orion as it flies behind the
Moon
now you are seeing the Earth you are
seeing home you are seeing yourself in
that image right there as Orion is 232
000 miles away from planet Earth
now less than four minutes away from our
expected loss of signal as Orion travels
behind the Moon
while behind the moon Orion will perform
the outbound powered flyby which the
team here in Mission Control is ready
for
flight director Rick labrode pulled the
team everyone is pulling go
everything still on track for the
outbound powered flyby burn now 20
minutes
away
this outbound powered flyby will send
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft once
around the Moon toward entry into
distant retrograde orbit following this
Orion will remain in the distant
retrograde orbit for one long elliptical
around the Moon which will last about
six days now this is different than what
was done during the Apollo program when
the spacecraft orbited much closer to
the moon now this orbit is called
distant due to the High Altitude from
the moon it's about 40 000 miles past
the moon in its orbit
this is actually 30 000 miles farther
than the previous record set during
Apollo 13 and will be the farthest in
space any spacecraft built for humans
will have ever flown
this orbit is called retrograde because
Orion will travel around the Moon
opposite the direction the moon travels
around Earth
distant retrograde orbit provides a
highly stable orbit where little fuel is
required to stay for an extended trip in
deep space and allows the opportunity to
put Orion's systems to the test in an
environment far from Earth
we are now less than two minutes away
from our anticipated loss of signal as
Orion travels behind the Moon
as we continue to get live views here
for the next minute or so we will
potentially see the Earth start to go
just behind the moon as Orion travels
behind the Moon
we will not have Earth views of course
because the moon will be blocking the
Orion spacecraft however we do
anticipate in acquisition of signal at 6
59 a.m Central
it's about a 34 Minute loss of signal at
which point we hope to regain
Communications with the spacecraft
five seconds away from our anticipated
loss of signal
and we do have loss of signal again this
is a 33
34 Minute four second loss of signal
Orion is now behind the moon and we are
in a period of anticipated loss of
signal
this is because the Moon is blocking the
signal to the deep space Network we are
looking ahead to the outbound powered
flyby burn which will take place with
the orbital maneuvering system in less
than 17 minutes from now at 6 44 a.m
Central
if you're just joining us Orion
continues to fly behind the moon we are
now 31 minutes away from our anticipated
acquisition of signal
and just 15 minutes away from today's
outbound powered flyby
so as we continue to make our way behind
the moon we do have that anticipated
loss of signal that we've been
discussing but right now I do have a
very special guest joining me we have
NASA flight director Zeb Scoville who is
going to chat with us a little bit about
this moment what it means to him and
what we can look forward to upcoming so
Zeb I can't imagine how special this
moment must feel tell me a little bit
about what this is like
this is one of those days that you've
been thinking about and dreaming about
for a long long time I remember when I
was a kid just dreaming about being an
astronaut and going to work at Nasa and
when I got here we were flying shuttle
and we were building a space station and
flying it and you know that is an
incredible vehicle but on the horizon
was always
how Humanity was going to get back to
the moon and this morning we just saw
the Earth set behind the moon as we take
the next human rated vehicle around the
Moon
preparing to bring humans back there
within a few years this is this is game
changer
absolutely and so we are
said right now and this is important
because we have a burn upcoming the OPF
burn can you talk to us a little bit
about what that burn is the purpose of
it and why it's important
owned powered flyby is the name of the
burn
because it's going to uh adjust the
trajectory of Orion so as we've been
flying towards it from Earth we're going
to loop around behind it use the gravity
to sort of give us a boost and then this
burn will put us into a trajectory that
brings us out to what's called a distant
retrograde orbit so this is about a 50
000 mile orbit above the surface of the
Moon where we can get set up in a stable
War but we're actually going to spend
several days in that orbit before we
come back around the Moon once again and
do another burn on the return end to
bring us back towards Earth
great well we're really looking forward
to that burn it's now just about 12
minutes away everything's still uh go
for that burn which is great news now I
think the question on everyone's mind is
the next time we do this we're going to
have crew on board so how is that going
to be different or is it going to be
different
I mean the crew really puts human in in
the human space flight right and that's
the whole reason why we're doing this is
to get uh get Humanity back on the
surface of the Moon there's just an
incredible amount that we have to learn
this is not like
um uh Apollo this is not a repeat of
Apollo what we're going to do in the
architectures we're going to be setting
up the locations we're going to go to
are going to really unlock a lot of the
the capabilities of the Moon the
research on the moon ability to go
explore beyond the moon and and the
solar system onto Mars there's areas of
the South Pole that will have
um volatile resources locked ice from
4.6 billion years ago last time I
checked the recipe for ice was hydrogen
and oxygen which by the way is also
Rocket Fuel and you can breathe it and
you can drink it and it really enables
sort of a long-term architecture on the
moon and so this is the first step when
we come back with crew on on Artemis 2
they're going to be doing a a real crew
test Rundown out of the vehicle testing
all the life support systems and making
sure they function with the human in the
loop elements of it and so that mission
will bring it and and do a short flyby
of the Moon before it comes back and
then Artemis 3 will get us onto the
surface
and we are really looking forward to
that but first today's OPF burn so I
really appreciate you taking some time
to chat with me about this I know you're
very busy so I'll let you get back to
your console position but really thank
you so much Seb we really appreciate it
you're very welcome thank you so
pleasure to be here
we're now less than 10 minutes away from
today's outbound powered flyby burn
foreign
as you see in this graphic on your
screen that is driven by real-time
Telemetry we are about 830 miles away
from the Moon
now we do not have
signal with Orion right now because the
Moon is blocking its ability to
communicate with the deep space Network
however we do anticipate regaining the
communication with Orion in about 25
minutes from now
but before then will be the moment we've
all been waiting for the OPF burn which
is slated to occur at 6 44 a.m Central
just eight minutes from now
we're now 23 minutes away from our
anticipated acquisition of signal with
Orion again the vehicle continues to fly
behind the Moon it is now 764 miles
above the lunar surface but at the time
of closest approach will be 81 miles
above the surface now we do have the
outbound powered flyby burn coming up in
about
6 minutes and 40 seconds from now but
this maneuver was first done during
Apollo 8 on Christmas Eve 54 years ago
Apollo 8 was the first crude spacecraft
to leave low earth orbit in the first
human space flight to reach the moon the
crew of Frank Borman James Lovell and
Bill Anders orbited the moon 10 times
without Landing before splashing down on
December 27
1968. while Apollo 8 completed 10 orbits
around the Moon about 60 miles above the
surface once Orion emerges from The Far
Side of the Moon it will slingshot out
to distant retrograde orbit about 30 000
miles away from the earth this orbit is
critical for key tests and to evaluate
how Orion performs in deep space and
this will be the furthest any human
rated spacecraft will have ever traveled
away from Earth but for now let's take a
quick look back on that historic Apollo
8 mission now
while Apollo 8 originally was an earth
orbital Mission exercising an Aluma
module but the lunar module was way
behind that the people in the NASA came
up with the idea of moving Apollo 8
balloon orbital Mission why don't we
send the command service module of
Apollo 8 to orbit the Moon and we can
learn a lot about the communication
system the navigation system how the
moon's gravity would affect the orbiting
spacecraft look for a suitable Landing
spots
well I got into the big Saturn V this
would be the first time that man had
actually launched on a Saturn V that I
thought to myself after this four months
of heavy training and like I said you
know I'm actually gonna go to the Moon
we had orbited the Earth first of all
I'm gonna check our spacecraft out then
when everything was lying and the
spacecraft looked fine to go to the Moon
we live a third stage for a second time
trajectory and guidance we could
actually Coast all the way to the Moon
and after a while you could look back
and see the Earth getting smaller and
smaller
people on Earth tend to follow The Far
Side of the Moon the dark side but
that's a misnomer on our flight the moon
was between the Earth and the Sun The
Far Side was lit by the Sun and we saw
The Far Side you know we were like three
school kids looking to a candy store
window I guess just staring at the
unnamed craters as they slowly passed us
by we were busy shooting pictures of
lunar surface for the lunar Landing
sites for upcoming lunar Landings and
then suddenly I looked out the window
and here was this gorgeous orb coming up
and I thought holy moly
and they're over the lunar landscape was
the Earth
the Earth was beautiful it was the only
thing in the whole universe that had any
color I had fought to have a long lens
in Color Film I didn't have a light
meter just banged off a dozen or so
pictures changing the f-stop each click
I put my thumb up to the window of the
spacecraft and I could completely hide
the Earth behind my thumb the Earth is a
mere Speck
in the Milky Way galaxy
[Music]
a Merry Christmas
God bless all of you all of you on The
Good Earth
[Music]
if you're just joining us Orion is
currently behind the moon and we are in
a period of anticipated loss of signal
as the moon blocks the signal of the
deep space Network
we are looking ahead to the outbound
powered flyby burn which will take place
with the orbital maneuvering system
about two minutes from now at 6 44 a.m
Central
at this time Orion is about 670 miles
above the lunar surface
during its time of closest approach
Orion will be about 81 miles above the
surface of the Moon
we're now 1 minute and 45 seconds away
from today's outbound powered flyby burn
this burn will last for two minutes and
30 seconds
[Music]
this burn will occur with Orion's
orbital maneuvering system or Ohm's
engine which was successfully checked
out on Tuesday following the liftoff of
Orion aboard the space launch system
from the Kennedy Space Center in Florida
the ohms engine performing spectacularly
so far
while this is the first flight for the
ohms engine as a part of the Artemis
program it actually flew on 19 space
shuttle flights beginning with sts-41g
in October 1984 and ending with sts-112
in October 2002.
we're now just 40 seconds away from the
ohms engine getting to flex its firing
capabilities on the back side of the
moon
less than 30 seconds until today's burn
15 seconds until the burn begins
and we anticipate the outbound powered
flyby burn to have begun
again because we are behind the back
side of the moon we do not have
communications with the Orion spacecraft
just yet but we do anticipate acquiring
that signal in 15 minutes and 50 seconds
from now
at that time we should be able to
evaluate performance of the OPF burn and
have some more information about how the
burn went
30 seconds into the burn two minutes
remaining in today's outbound powered
flyby burn
one minute into the outbound powered
flyby burn
this outbound powered flyby will send
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft once
around the Moon toward entry into that
distant retrograde orbit
Orion will remain in the distant
retrograde orbit for one long elliptical
orbit around the Moon lasting about six
days
this orbit is called distant due to the
High Altitude from the moon it's about
40 000 miles past the moon in its orbit
which is actually 30 000 miles farther
than the previous record set during
Apollo 13 and will be the farthest in
space any spacecraft built for humans
will have ever flown
30 seconds remaining in today's burn
now once in this distant retrograde
orbit the orbit will is called distant
is called retrograde because Orion will
travel around the Moon opposite the
direction the moon travels around Earth
distant retrograde orbit provides a
highly stable orbit where little fuel is
required to stay for an extended trip in
deep space in order to put Orion's
systems to the test in an environment
far from Earth
and the outbound powered flyby burn
should be complete
and we are less than 14 minutes away
from our anticipated acquisition of our
signal with Orion
the next Milestone will look ahead
towards in our coverage today is when
Orion will complete its closest approach
to the lunar surface in 10 minutes from
now Orion will be flying 81 miles above
the lunar surface
that closest approach occurring at 6 57
a.m Central 7 57 a.m Eastern
then just two minutes from the time of
closest approach we do anticipate our
acquisition of signal
if you are just joining us the Orion
spacecraft is currently flying behind
the Moon
we are in a period of loss of signal
due to the fact that the Moon is
blocking Orion's ability to communicate
with the deep space network but we do
anticipate gaining signal on the deep
space Network in 11 minutes and 30
seconds from now
at 6 44 a.m Central Time Orion's
orbital maneuvering system engine
completed a 2 minute and 30 second burn
this burn is called the outbound powered
flyby burn now again because we are
behind the moon we will not be able to
have data from the Orion spacecraft to
evaluate how the burn performance was
but we do expect to learn a little bit
more about that once we come back behind
the Moon
on this graphic you see on your screen
that is of course the Orion spacecraft
and the large engine that you see in the
middle of the spacecraft there is the
orbital maneuvering system that was the
engine that just performed the burn we
anticipate that burn to have lasted two
minutes and 30 seconds
the ohms engine or orbital maneuvering
system engine provides six thousand
pounds of thrust and can steer the
spacecraft and can be used in some abort
cases to safely return Orion to Earth
and in this animation you're also seeing
some of the auxiliary engines on board
Orion
these are all also located on the bottom
of the service module in four sets of
two
each of these engines provides about 100
pounds of thrust
there are also 24 smaller engines
grouped into six pods which provide
attitude control for Orion
they can be fired individually as needed
to move the spacecraft in different
directions and rotate it into different
positions so in total the service module
has 33 engines
but today's burn again we anticipate to
have
been
we anticipate the burn to occurred with
the orbital maneuvering system or ohms
engine
we are now five minutes away from
Orion's closest approach to the lunar
surface
as Orion continues to travel behind the
moon we are still in a period of
anticipated loss of signal as the moon
blocks the signal to the deep space
Network
we are anticipating the acquisition of
signal in less than seven minutes from
now
at 6 44 a.m Central just about 9 minutes
and 30 seconds ago commands were sent
for the outbound powered flyby burn tour
occur with the orbital maneuvering
system engine or ohms engine onboard
Orion which sends Orion close enough to
the lunar surface to leverage the moon's
gravitational force and swing the
spacecraft once around the Moon toward
entry into distant retrograde orbit
following this Orion will remain in the
distant retrograde orbit for one half
elliptical orbit around the Moon which
will last about six days
the orbit is called distant due to the
High Altitude from the Moon which is
about 40 000 miles past the moon in its
orbit
this will be thirty thousand miles
farther than the previous record set
during Apollo 13 and will also be the
farthest in space any spacecraft built
for humans will have ever flown
the orbit is called retrograde because
Orion will travel around the Moon
opposite the direction the moon travels
around Earth
distant retrograde orbit provides a
highly stable orbit where little fuel is
required to stay for an extended trip in
deep space in order to put Orion's
systems to the test in an environment
far from Earth
now this orbit is different than the
orbit done during the Apollo program in
which the spacecraft and its crew
orbited much closer to the lunar surface
in a more circular fashion
distant retrograde orbit is important
because it helps us to learn about how a
spacecraft functions in a deep space
environment
as part of the Artemis program The
Gateway program is building a small
human-tended space station which will
orbit the Moon and provide extensive
capabilities to support NASA's Artemis
campaign
gateway's capabilities for supporting
sustained exploration and research in
deep space include docking ports for a
variety of visiting spacecraft space for
crew to live and work and onboard
science investigations to study
heliophysics human health and Life
Sciences among other areas
we are expecting the acquisition of
signal to occur in four minutes from now
at this time we do expect Orion to be
completing its closest approach to the
lunar surface Orion should be just about
81 miles above the surface of our
closest Celestial neighbor
at this time of closest approach Orion
flying at a lunar latitude of 6.5
degrees and a lunar longitude of 120
degrees Orion is fairly close to the
equator at this time
now just two minutes away from our
anticipated acquisition of signal
one minute and 30 seconds until the
anticipated acquisition of signal
again Orion is currently flying behind
the back side of the moon having
completed its closest Approach at 6 57
a.m Central just 81 miles above the
lunar surface
less than 30 minutes 30 seconds rather
until our anticipated acquisition of
signal
the mood's certainly a bit suspenseful
here in mission control as we await to
Orion to emerge from the back side of
the moon
we're standing by for acquisition of
signal
and we do have confirmation of an
acquisition acquisition of signal on the
deep space Network in Goldstone
this view on your screen of planet Earth
taken from Orion's solar array Wing
camera or saw camera
standing on the shoulders of the Giants
of the Apollo generation Orion now
carries forward the torch of the Artemis
generation as it emerges from behind the
moon and earthrise of our pale blue dot
and it's 8 billion human inhabitants now
coming into view
with this successful acquisition of
signal from the Orion spacecraft the
team here in Mission Control Houston
will evaluate the spacecraft systems to
evaluate performance of the outbound
power to fly by burn which occurred 18
minutes and 50 seconds ago
and you're looking at this view on your
screen from the Orion spacecraft as it
looks back at Planet Earth having
launched just five days ago Orion is now
over 230
000 miles away from Earth
Orion emerged from the back side of the
moon just minutes ago
after completing the outbound powered
flyby burn
that up burn occurring 21 minutes ago
while behind the moon Orion completed
its closest approach to the moon at a
distance of 80 miles above the surface
and you're looking at a live view inside
the Orion spacecraft this is of course
an uncrewed test flight but we do have a
couple of purposeful passengers that
have hopped a ride on board Orion you're
looking at one there on the left of your
screen
that is a moon Akin wearing the Orion
crew survival suit
this is the space this is the space suit
that crew will wear during Dynamic
phases of flight once we do have a crew
on board
particularly during launch and entry
situations
the ox or Orion crew survival suit can
help keep astronauts alive if Ryan were
to lose cabin pressure during the
journey out to the Moon
Orion is the ox rather is equipped to
up to six days of life support systems
as the crew makes their way back to
Earth
and as part of this uncrewed test flight
there's a variety of sensors and data
that will be pulled from the Orion crew
survival suit
to inform further design ahead of crude
flight test as part of Artemis 2.
and this view of our home planet taken
from 229
000 miles away from the Orion spacecraft
following
it's outbound powered flyby burn behind
the Moon
at its closest approach Orion flew 81
miles above the lunar surface
on there
is
foreign
hours and 27 minutes into the historic
flight of Artemis 1.
the Orion spacecraft just recently
emerged from the back side of the moon
after completing the outbound powered
flyby
coming up at met five days six hours and
52 minutes which is about 54 minutes
after the OPF burnout Orion is slated to
fly extremely close to the Apollo 11
Landing site
the Apollo 11 Landing site named
Tranquility base was where Commander
Neil Armstrong and lunar module pilot
Buzz Aldrin touched down on July 20th
1969 53 years ago
as oh Ryan continues to swing around the
Moon toward entry into distant
retrograde orbit
we were just getting some views of the
Earth from about 220 000 miles away we
do expect to get those views again here
momentarily but you are looking at a
live view inside Mission Control Houston
where NASA flight director Judd frieling
is leading the team on console
33 minutes ago Orion completed the
outbound powered flyby burn which lasted
two minutes and 30 seconds which sent
Orion close enough to the lunar surface
to leverage the moon's gravitational
force and swing the spacecraft around
the Moon toward entry into distant
retrograde orbit
next up for Orion we'll be ins will be
insertion into distant retrograde orbit
where it will remain for one half long
elliptical orbit around the moon this
period will last about days
following this Orion will complete a
similar maneuver in which it flies
behind the moon in a return power flyby
and as you might expect just the
opposite of the outbound powered flyby
this maneuver will help put Orion on a
trajectory to return back to Earth and
splash down in the Pacific Ocean on
December 11th
and another view of the flight director
on Console today during today's Opera
operations Rick labrode
and coming in to your view on your
screen right there in the Reddit jacket
is the Johnson Space Center Senate
director Vanessa weish
horrible
ability
those
oh
and if you're just joining us Orion has
emerged from the back side of the moon
after completing the outbound powered
flyby 42 minutes ago
this burn lasted two minutes and 30
seconds and sent Orion close enough to
the lunar surface to leverage the moon's
gravitational force and swing the
spacecraft once around the Moon toward
entry into distant retrograde orbit
once inserted in the distant retrograde
orbit Orion will remain in the distant
retrograde orbit for one half elliptical
orbit around the Moon
this will last about six days
uh
foreign
we're just six minutes away from the
anticipated flyover of the Apollo 11
Landing site Tranquility base
we anticipate that flyover to occur at 7
37 a.m Central
during the flyover Orion will be 1 384
statute miles above the landing site
and you are looking at a live view
inside Mission Control Houston where
NASA flight director Rick labrode is on
console
leading the team here in Mission Control
following the outbound powered flyby
burn which occurred 49 minutes ago
this two minute and 30 second burn
utilized the orbital maneuvering system
or Ohm's engine onboard the Orion
spacecraft
and help set the stage for decent
retrograde insertion
all right
we're now two minutes away from the
anticipated flyover of the Apollo 11
Landing site Tranquility base
Orion will be 1 384 statute miles above
the landing site
and at this time we do expect Orion to
be flying over the Apollo 11 Landing
site at Tranquility base
Orion is
1384 statute miles above the landing
site
Tranquility base was where Commander
Neil Armstrong and lunar module pilot
Buzz Aldrin landed on the moon for the
very first time on July 20th 1969 53
years ago
thank you
or
foreign
foreign
Video One
is
um
and with the outbound powered flyby burn
now complete and Orion having completed
its closest approach to the moon at a
distance of 80 miles above the surface
that will wrap up our coverage for today
but we'll continue to post daily updates
about the mission on the Artemis blog at
blogs.nasa.gov
Artemis and we'll also be posting
updates on our social media accounts as
well later today we'll have a briefing
at 4 pm Central 5 PM Eastern where
representatives from NASA will discuss
the outbound power to fly by which we
hope you'll tune in for and we'll be
live on NASA TV covering the distant
retrograde orbit insertion Friday
beginning at 3 30 PM Central 4 30 PM
eastern time until then this is Mission
Control Houston
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]